fällt ihnen das auch auf liebe zuschauer
irgendwas ist anders ich habe heute auf
der straße mehrmals lächelnde menschen
gesehen
einer hat mich sogar gegrüßt hoffnung
liegt in der luft deutschland impft sich
in einen rausch die instanzen im freien
fall
das ist doch nicht mehr normal das ist
doch nicht normal wo bleiben denn die
neuesten mutanten meldung ich habe nicht
so gewöhnt an die täglichen warnungen
von karl lauterbach sie auch ja aber
selbst dr dom klingt plötzlich nicht
mehr wie er selbst meine theorie ist ja
der mann wurde von außerirdischen
entführt durch einen gut gelaunten
doppelgänger ersetzt wir sind an einem
wendepunkt gab jetzt werden die
fallzahlen erst langsam und dann
schneller zurückgehen und der sommer
gehört sehr gut sagen ich bin fest davon
überzeugt ist ein sommer der befreiung
jahren es geschafft ich schaffe das
jetzt das ist ein guter sommer wird wie
die allermeisten wird das ein sehr guter
sommer werden ich habe offen gesagt mit
einem sehr guten sommer schon im januar
gerechnet
[Applaus]
gefühlt ist schon sommer leute der beste
sommer aller zeiten karl lauterbach
formerly known as die gdp heute
unterwegs als dj inzidenz mit dance
tanzt er verkündete die große zeit der
pandemie ist vorbei ja dann global so
gar nicht und auch bei uns sind zwei
drittel noch nicht mal erst geimpft aber
wurscht wir brauchen jetzt tatsächlich
mal gute nachrichten und urlaub und
party sowie schon jetzt ein bisschen an
den tischen aber nicht ausstehen
wirklich schön sind zum leiden zählt
aber wir dürfen sport spaß mit safety
first und erwin fast der heidi von
händen an den impfpass oder so
deutschland freut sich über das comeback
der außengastronomie zu recht weil man
sich draußen mit etwas abstand praktisch
nicht anstecken kann und die
reisebranche darf auch endlich wieder
hoffen denn das schlagwort der stunde
heißt revenge travel rache reisen
angestaute reiselust und angespartes
geld brechen sich bahn
man bucht wie verrückt ist alles
verständlich aber warum revenge rache an
wem die idee ist wohl sobald die politik
den käfig auf macht stehe ich sekunden
später wütend am flughafen habe richtig
den kaffee auf nach dem langen lockdown
und wenn die lufthansa tours gesagt gute
reise streich halbkreis im pfleger
trinke ich eingequetschte auf dem
letzten freien mittelplatz tomatensaft
obwohl ich von dem fast kotzen muss aus
rache dann fliege ich nach mallorca aber
über hawaii um es den blöden planeten zu
zeigen und auf malle hole ich dann in
drei minuten alles nach was ich in der
korona diktatur nicht durfte restaurant
fitnessstudio disco und natürlich
sangria saufen dabei merke ich dass ich
mein ladegerät in deutschland vergessen
habe und fliegt direkt wieder nach hause
das wird im bus eine lehre sein
rache reisen werden super namen für ein
reisebüro oder inzidenz bundesweit unter
100 außer in thüringen wahrscheinlich
gottes rache für hans-georg maßen
theorie insgesamt hellt sich die
stimmung aber eindeutig auf bei uns in
deutschland das merkt man auch bei den
demos von querdenkern und co
mittlerweile sind die demos deutlich
kleiner
am nachmittag tritt müller auf in
münchen vor relativ wenig publikum wo
sind hier die menschen ja also sie hören
dann eine tiefe enttäuschung heraus
na gut dann haben wir halt nicht anders
verdient dann gehen halt unter
sie gehen unter wird bald verfilmt als
der untergang
also deutschland plant urlaub freut sich
mit der gastronomie alles soweit richtig
ich habe nur das vage gefühl wir
vergessen schon wieder irgendwie richtig
diese jüngeren menschen die gibt es hier
ja auch noch und während die ersten
nagelstudios aufmachen sind die meisten
schüler immer noch im wechsel wenn ich
sogar im distanz unterricht zum glück
gucken die jugendlichen eh kein
fernsehen
sonst könnten sie sich an solche
versprechungen hier erinnern wenn wir
öffnen als erstes bei den schulen und
wenn wir schließen als letztes bei den
schulen kinderbetreuungsangebote egal ob
in kita schule oder kindertagespflege
müssen als erstes wieder öffnungs
schritte gehen
ja franziska giffey alias dr
das nach dem rücktritt diese woche ihre
familienministerium von der justiz
ministerin mal eben mit erledigt wird so
wie man übers wochenende auf die katze
vom nachbarn aufpasst es sagt einiges
über den stellenwert von familien und
kindern in diesem land auch bei menschen
stehen die jungen menschen ganz hinten
in der schlange
immerhin hat jens sparen die
priorisierung ab dem siebten juni
aufgehoben
dann darf sich also jeder deutsche über
16 um einen impftermin bemühen führt zu
mehr tempo und weniger bürokratie aber
auch zu sehr viel erwartung
erwartungshaltung denn die nachfrage ist
natürlich viel größer als das angebot
als hausärztin hast du also völlig neue
möglichkeiten ist jeden tag wie so ein
casting die leute machen im moment alles
für ihre spritze alles manche war es
nicht packen ihre ärztin einen kuchen
wenn man die zeit hat andere versuchen
das mit teuren geschenken ganz
verzweifelte bieten ihren eigenen mann
zum abputzen an
wenn es hilft und am ende kriegt jeder
glückliche impfling bei uns einen
kleinen aufkleber in seinen gelben la
bringen impfpass die digitale version
des passes die kommt leider doch erst
frühestens ende juni
was sagt man dazu von den machern von
sie haben uns leider zu spät um masten
gekümmert und wir haben uns leider zu
spät um tests gekümmert kommt jetzt wir
haben uns leider zu spät um den
digitalen eben spaß gekümmert
immer dasselbe in meiner seit november
wissen wir dass es mehrere zugelassene
impfstoffe gibt trotzdem beschließt das
corona kabinett in berlin erst am 22
februar die beschaffung einer digitalen
impft bescheinigung am 19 märz wurde der
entsprechende auftrag an ibm deutschland
vergeben warum so spät
früher wäre besser wenn ich dafür aber
jetzt schauen wir doch mal was wir
gerade dabei sind umzusetzen wir setzen
gerade einen weltweiten maßstab als
europäische union sind wir geil leute
ein einfaches sorry jetzt auch getan
stattdessen weltstandard sparen schiebt
den datenschutz vor
dabei sind andere länder die sich auch
an europäischen datenschutz halten
längst
hier viel weiter als wir schweden zb
egal in welcher region sie geimpft
werden alle datenbanken sind mit dem
digitalen zentralregister vernetzt wenn
das eu zertifikat kommt haben wir schon
alle informationen und jeder kann es
sofort herunterladen
angeber gut mit der hightech nation
schweben können wir uns natürlich nicht
vergleichen
die haben köttbullar erfunden schade so
schade dass wenig auch so schlau waren
die impf daten von allen geimpften
gleich digital zu erfassen
es war blöd jetzt müssen wahrscheinlich
millionen deutsche demnächst nochmal zum
hausarzt um ihren gelben lappen zu
digitalisieren
weil die ärzte ihr sonst nichts zu tun
haben dazu begrüße ich dr sebastian
pufpaff von der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung nordrhein
herr dr wie stressig wird das jetzt für
sie wenn die ganze wegen gleiche beiden
herreweghe nicht zappeln alles klar
bavaria und extra
ich bin zu verleihen herr schlimmste was
sie noch mal am 17 juni wird die
priorisierung aufgehoben aber das heißt
nicht dass ich an dem tag schon alle
deutschen impfen kann gea machten auch
nicht nein meine mutter ist keine [ __ ]
aber vielleicht wissen sie da mehr danke
ja sie mich ja auch leute gibt es hätte
so waren wir richtig
wochenlang haben wir hausärzte gesagt
gebt uns dass mit dem impfen wir wollen
mehr impfen warum haben wir das gemacht
waren wir da besoffen jetzt werden wir
überrannt ich mache nichts mehr außer
impfen
sie glauben gar nicht was die leute sich
alles ausdenken um ihre spritze zu
kriegen ja wir haben schon skurrile
situationen gehabt als die arztpraxen
freigegeben wurden kamen die ganze
familie in weiß an
der mann sagte er sei arzt sinnvoll sei
auch ärztin die kinder waren übrigens
auch ganz in weiß angezogen und die
sollten wir dann auch direkt mit impfen
natürlich fan feier sagt mein kind ist
so das baby hatten weißen kittel an kann
ich ja nie überprüfen oder gibt ja auch
kinderärzte
der ist nicht gut wirklich mir steht es
bis hier was soll ich noch alles machen
für jede impfung acht seiten papier kam
ausdrucken plus stundenlange
diskussionen mit asozialen rentnern die
auf bayern tick bestehen bei ihnen ihre
eigenen enkel scheißegal sind da war den
ich aus dass die politik nicht die eier
hat den grünfinken zu sagen wie sehr ich
kriege astra astra ja gut dafür gibt es
aber eine wissenschaftliche erklärung im
september ist wohl eine sogenannte
bundestagswahl und die jungen sind bei
uns eine minderheit ihr leben über 23
millionen wahlberechtigte über 60 jahre
aber doch nicht mehr lange und bald
kommen die ganzen hand fressen dann
nochmal an gewackelt und wollen von mir
den digitalen impfpass üblich dass
beklagte einwohnermeldeamt oder was ich
hab kein bock mehr recht nicht ich spüre
da zwischen den zeilen eine gewisse
bitterkeit ich spüre überhaupt nichts
mehr
seit jahren herr welke ich für nichts
mehr reisezeit hier drin und was viele
nicht wissen nebenbei sondern auch noch
sogenannte kranke behandeln dafür hatte
ich ja auch nicht mal studiert
stattdessen höhe war sich den ganzen tag
so was ja noch eine sehr lustige
situation dass ein mann sagte meine frau
möchte schwanger werden und deswegen
möchte er geimpft werden
versteh ich nicht meine frau ist
schwanger können sie die inseln sondern
die möchte schwanger werden deshalb
müssen sie mich impfen ich würde sagen
kompromiss ich schwer eine frau aber das
wollen ja viele nicht egal
er wirke ich sage es ihnen ehrlich ich
habe den sommer schon komplett abgehakt
ich eben sich jetzt einfach durch bis
september und dann können sich alle am
arsch lecken gerade gebucht vier wochen
herbstferien auf den malediven es wird
der geilste herbst erwartet na gut ich
meine neue studien sagen die impfung
hält wahrscheinlich nur sechs monate an
der spd-politiker lauterbach rechnet
sogar damit dass wegen der virus
mutation bereits im herbst eine
zusätzliche impfung nötig sein könnte
[Applaus]
auch sebastian pufpaff
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll auslasten abo
da